und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber guten abend gibt
reisefreiheit cia dieser wunsch der
regierten an ihre regierung ist
vielleicht nur der zweitgrößte im corona
text nach kita und schule öffnungen aber
bald sind ferien und dann ist das thema
schule erstmal weg und reisefreiheit
führt die wunschliste da will die
regierung nicht mehr im wege stehen
die tage der globalen reisewarnungen
sind gezählt europas grenzen gehen auf
für ferien und mehr
der rest der welt muss sich im
einzelfall bewähren
florian neumann berichtet europa ohne
grenzen titelt das heute journal im märz
1995 als europäische staaten erstmals
grenzkontrollen aufgeben
europa ohne grenzen 25 jahre später
verkündet die deutsche regierung fast
dieselbe nachricht noch einmal die
journalisten auf abstand der minister
ganz ohne pathos
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das kabinett hat heute auf meinen
vorschlag hin beschlossen dass die
bestehenden bindenden grenzkontrollen
mit dem 15 juni 2020 beendet werden
seit mitte märz hatte an deutschen
grenzen wie hier im bayerischen
kiefersfelden der ausnahmezustand
regiert hereinkam nur wer einen
triftigen grund vorweisen konnte fast
200.000 menschen wurde die einreise
verweigert ein harter einschnitt auch
für die wirtschaft die grenzkontrollen
führen dazu dass es wartezeiten gibt an
seine grenzen
dass es war noch unsicherheit gibt das
ist in vielen branchen die auf schnelle
lieferungen angewiesen das sind ein
problem lieferketten unterbrochen corona
infektionsketten aber auch der eine
wertet die grenzkontrollen heute als
großen erfolg der andere als großes
ärgernis beide kommen aus der union
ich würde im zweifel dem kabinett immer
schutzmaßnahmen empfehlen auch wenn sie
dann vielleicht mehr als das notwendige
umfassen wir müssen uns vorbereiten auf
eine neue pandemie und dann müssen wir
das schaffen ohne die grenzen zu
schließen
wir brauchen gesundheits kooperation
über die grenze hinweg aber ein virus
lässt sich nicht an einer grenze
aufhalten
ohnehin hat die neue alte reisefreiheit
ihre grenzen
zeitgleich nämlich verlängert die
bundesregierung heute auch die
reisewarnung für 160 staaten weltweit
darunter etwa die türkei bis zum 31
august 2020 anders als bei unseren
europäischen nachbarn haben wir für den
rest der welt heute noch nicht die
gemeinsamen belastbaren datengrundlagen
die einen nur eingeschränkten
reiseverkehr ohne unkalkulierbare
risiken wieder möglich machen
wenn wir nicht zu einer geregelten
öffnung der grenzen kommen und auch zu
mehr möglichkeiten zu reisen dann ist
das ein todesstoß für die deutsche
reisewirtschaft der so nicht hinnehmbar
ist
was ist hinnehmbar im kampf gegen das
virus grenzkontrollen innerhalb europas
vorerst nicht mehr bis zur nächsten
krise zumindest auch die politik nutzt
wie der reisefreiheit außenminister maß
flog heute über die außengrenzen der eu
hinaus zum ersten mal nach dem log down
und wählte als ziel israel ein hotspot
ganz anderer art da bahnt sich befeuert
vom friedensplan des präsidenten trump
ein neuer konflikt an israel will unter
dem neu ins amt gewählten benjamin
netanyahu am ersten juli beginnen sich
teile des westjordanlandes
einzuverleiben
der deutsche außenminister versucht
alles um das zu verhindern
am selben tag am ersten juli übernimmt
deutschland nämlich die eu
ratspräsidentschaft und den vorsitz des
weltsicherheitsrates eine doppelte
schlüsselrolle und eine fatale lage für
deutschland das in diesem konflikt nicht
neutral sein kann und nicht neutral sein
will
nicola albrecht berichtet aus brüssel
als ganz besonderer freund wie er sich
bezeichnet hatte bundesaußenminister maß
schon lange darauf gewartet wieder
einmal nach israel reisen zu dürfen das
zeichen der freundschaft auf der maske
geben er und sein amtskollege ashkenasi
sich betont locker
doch im mittelpunkt des besuchs ein
heikles thema israels an aktionspläne
mars setzt auf sanfte kritik mit
konsequenzen zu drohen hält er für
falsch
gemeinsam mit der europäischen union
sind wir der ansicht dass eine energie
aktion nicht mit internationalem recht
vereinbar wäre jetzt ist die zeit der
diplomatie und des dialoges
der israelische außenminister zeigt sich
unbeeindruckt reicht den ball weiter an
die palästinenser wir erwarten von der
internationalen gemeinschaft dass sie
den palästinensern klar macht wenn sie
sich des dialogs verweigern wird das in
palästinensischen interessen nicht
dienen
hier im jordantal nur eines der
möglichen gebiete das annektiert werden
könnte leben rund 60.000 palästinenser
unter israelischer besatzung einer von
ihnen ist hasan mohammad die große
politik interessiere ihn eigentlich
nicht er persönlich habe bislang keine
echten probleme mit den jüdischen
siedlern sie geben ihm arbeit erklärt er
uns doch eine annexion mache ihm nun
doch angst ich bin palästinenser und
will unter palästinensischer
souveränität leben was soll aus uns
werden wenn annektiert wird welchen
status sollen wir haben die jüdischen
siedler mittlerweile rund 600.000 üben
indes schon lange druck auf die
regierung aus endlich zu annektieren was
ohnehin irland sei die usa haben dafür
grünes licht gegeben allerdings sie
trumps nahost plan auch einen
palästinensischen staat vor inakzeptabel
meint man hier zwischen dem jordan und
im mittelmeer darf kein terroristischer
palästinensischer staat gegründet werden
angekündigt hat der israelische premier
netanyahu die annexion für den ersten
juli genau der tag an dem deutschland
die eu ratspräsidentschaft und den
vorsitz im un-sicherheitsrat übernimmt
kaum zeit verhärtete fronten und viel
druck für maß der sich dennoch schon
heute als vermittler an
das gespräch mit premier netanjahu
findet dann aber ohne presse stadt und
dem palästinensischen premierminister
spricht muss erst am abend bei seiner
weiterreise in jordanien per
video-konferenz wir haben immer die ein
die verhandelte einvernehmliche zwei
staaten lösung präferiert und ich glaube
deshalb wird es auch notwendig sein dass
auf allen seiten den worten jetzt
endlich taten folgen treffe ständig
leute die bereit sind zur verhandlung
aber die es nie bisher geschafft haben
sich zusammen an einen tisch zu setzen
der aufruf zu direkten verhandlungen in
der mission frieden für nahost sicher
kein falscher vorschlag die frage ist
wird er angenommen von einem freund aus
deutschland der neutraler vermittler
sein möchte wir erreichen heiko maas in
der jordanischen hauptstadt amman guten
abend herr minister hallo guten abend
herr kleber die erste reise nach der
korona zwangspause gleich in diese
verfahrene situation konnten sie denn
irgendetwas erreichen
naja das ist eine schwierige situation
in der wir uns befinden und wir wissen
dass sich deutschland damit
auseinandersetzen muss nicht nur weil
wir eine besondere verantwortung
gegenüber israel haben wir werden im
juli die präsidentschaft in der
europäischen union übernehmen wir werden
die präsidentschaft im sicherheitsrat
der vereinten nationen übernehmen
und sollte es hier zu aktionen kommen
dann werden das thema sein mit denen wir
uns beschäftigen müssen und deshalb
versuchen wir schon jetzt mit allen
seiten zu sprechen und dafür zu sorgen
dass das was alle wollen und was alle
auch immer behaupten nämlich dass sie
bereit sind zu gesprächen zu direkten
gesprächen zwischen den israelis und den
palästinensern
das den worten endlich taten folgen denn
wir glauben nicht dass mit aktionen wir
wirklich einen schritt weiter kommen wir
haben große sorgen was die
sicherheitsarchitektur in der region
angeht und deshalb ist das heute ein
auftakt gewesen um dazu beizutragen dass
diejenigen die eine einvernehmliche
lösung erzielen sollten sich endlich an
einen tisch setzen
wenn israel der freund
deutschlands im nahen osten entschlossen
ist diese annexion durch zu ziehen und
das steht immerhin im koalitionsvertrag
der jetzigen regierung was kann dann
ausgerechnet deutschland tun
doch nicht in den arm israels fallen und
das verhindern nein aber wir müssen
israel schon darauf hinweisen das habe
ich heute in jerusalem getan und zwar
bei allen gesprächen die ich geführt
habe
sowohl mit benjamin netanyahu als auch
mit benny gantz dass eine annexion nach
unserem blickwinkel nicht mit dem
internationalen recht vereinbar ist
wir sind nach wie vor der auffassung
dass ist nicht nur unsere auffassung
sondern in der frage ist auch die
europäische union einig dass wir eine
einvernehmliche verhandelte zwei staaten
lösung brauchen so wie es in vielen
internationalen verträgen festgelegt ist
und darüber sprechen wir mit den
beteiligten parteien nicht nur heute
sondern diese gespräche werden
fortgesetzt werden und das wird auch
nicht nicht nur deutschland sein die
sich dabei als dass wir uns dabei
einmischen das werden auch andere tun
denn wir wollen nicht dass die ohnehin
fragile sicherheitslage hier in der
region durch aktions entscheidung
weiterhin verschlimmert wird
ab ersten juli werden sie als
ratspräsident der außenminister auch für
europäische außenpolitik sprechen
die gibt es aber wenn es ernst wird
nicht denn es gibt völlige
unterschiedliche auffassungen innerhalb
der europäischen union was zu tun ist
wenn israel tatsächlich diesen schritt
geht und ob man drohen kann zb mit
sanktionen gibt es ganz verschiedene
positionen es gibt keine europäische was
machen sie da das was wir jetzt tun ist
ja darauf hinzuwirken dass es zu dieser
situation gar nicht erst kommt ich
glaube nicht dass es uns keinen schritt
weiter bringt wenn wir uns jetzt
gegenseitig bedrohungen überziehen das
ist jetzt die zeit für diplomatie in
dialog das ist sehr sehr schwierig und
bei der ausgangslage die wir heute haben
ich glaube ich kann man auch nicht
prognostizieren wo sich dinge hin
entwickeln aber wenn beide seiten sagen
dass sie bereit sind sich an einen tisch
zu setzen dann glaube ich ist es
sinnvoll dass ein land wie deutschland
in der rolle in der wir im juli sein
werden als
als präsidentin der europäischen union
wir werden den vorsitz im sicherheitsrat
der vereinten nationen haben mit dafür
zu sorgen dass diejenigen die behaupten
bereits zu sein für verhandlungen damit
auch endlich anfangen
sie sehen also eine chance zu einer
lösung in diesem konflikt und konnten
den leuten dort etwas sagen was sie
nicht schon hundertmal auch von
deutschland gehört haben ich glaube dass
es gerade jetzt ganz besonders wichtig
ist das noch einmal zu sagen wir haben
auf der israelischen seite deutlich
gemacht dass wir an aktionen nicht
anerkennen werden und wir werden nicht
die einzigen sein die sich so verhalten
wir haben aber auch der
palästinensischen seite gesagt dass sie
bereit sein muss zu gesprächen das ist
auch sinnvoll wäre wenn sie einen
eigenen vorschlag auf den tisch legt
nicht nur zu sagen dass das was im
moment vorliegt und das was als plan auf
den weg gebracht worden ist insbesondere
auch von den vereinigten staaten ist
falsch das reicht nicht
und deshalb habe ich auch die
palästinenser aufgefordert eigene
vorschläge auf den tisch zu legen und
damit eine grundlage zu haben
miteinander zu sprechen
noch ist nicht erster juli danke schön
herr minister und eine gute reise vielen
dank herr kleber dieser reise tag war
nicht lustig und er begann für den
minister morgens um halb vier
das heißt wir haben dieses gespräch um
21 uhr aufgezeichnet nachrichten von
gundula aus 34 jahre nach dem mord an
olof palme dem einstigen
ministerpräsidenten von schweden sind
die ermittlungen eingestellt worden
die staatsanwaltschaft bochum erklärte
man kenne den mutmaßlichen täter der sei
aber im jahr 2000 gestorben
damit bleibt der aufsehenerregende mord
an dem in schweden beliebten aber auch
angefeindeten sozialdemokraten
juristisch ungeklärt die
staatsanwaltschaft macht ist die
engström für die tat verantwortlich
der damals 52-jährige
versicherungsangestellte soll palme aus
politischen motiven erschoss
haben er habe die linke politik palmes
abgelehnt nach tagelangen spekulationen
ist die bundesregierung nun offiziell
über pläne der usa informiert worden
in deutschland stationierte us soldaten
möglicherweise abzuziehen
es gebe in der us-administration
entsprechende überlegungen bestätigte
eine regierungssprecherin
nach medienberichten erwägt us-präsident
trank 9500 der mehr als 34.000 us
soldaten aus deutschland abzuziehen
deutschland will wieder flüchtlinge in
not aufnehmen innenminister seehofer
erklärte es handele sich um 350 bis 500
minderjährige migranten aus den
flüchtlingslagern auf den griechischen
inseln die entweder krank sein oder
unbegleitet und jünger als 14 jahre
die meisten davon mädchen außerdem habe
deutschland italien und malta angeboten
jeweils 80 aus seenot gerettet migranten
zu übernehmen
das corona virus verbreitet sich nach
angaben der weltgesundheitsorganisation
derzeit besonders stark in südasien und
südamerika
dort gibt es nun die meisten
neuinfektionen seit beginn der pandemie
in brasilien gab es zuletzt mehr als
32.000 neue fälle an einem tag peru
liegt inzwischen auf platz acht der
weltweit am stärksten betroffenen länder
in asien verzeichnet indien viele
infizierte fast 280.000 auch im
benachbarten pakistan geht die
infektions kurve steil nach oben
ebenso in südafrika dort stieg die zahl
der neuinfektionen sprunghaft an
in den letzten 7 tagen um rund 50
prozent
angehörige von opfern der korona
pandemie in italien haben strafanzeige
erstattet bei der staatsanwaltschaft
bergamo gingen rund 50 klagen ein
die hinterbliebenen werfen den behörden
vor sperrzonen zu spät eingerichtet und
durch kürzungen im gesundheitssystem die
krise verschärft zu haben
in der provinz bergamo
sind etwa 3100 menschen im zusammenhang
mit dem virus gestorben
die region ist vergleichsweise schwer
betroffen
in berlin wurde heute eines der größten
zukunftsprojekte der uns zurzeit
regierenden vorgestellt energie aus
wasserstoff als treibstoff nicht in
erster linie für pkw mehr für fabriken
stahlkocher lkw und flugzeuge treibstoff
aus wasser aufgespalten in wasserstoff
und sauerstoff technisch ist das kein
großes problem aber es kostet viel viel
strom klima schützen wird die technik
nur wenn der strom für die produktion
aus co2 freien quellen kommt grüner
wasserstoff wasserstoff der mit fossilen
brennstoffen gewonnen wird aus
kohlekraftwerken etwa grauer wasserstoff
das ist ein klimakiller für eine tonne
treibstoff werden zehn tonnen co2
ausgestoßen
also muss es anders gehen im ganz ganz
großen stil
das soll ein deutscher exportschlager
werden
oliver deuker und fabian köhler bericht
die stahlproduktion der energiebedarf
ist enorm überwiegend umweltschädliche
kohle wird dabei eingesetzt dazu auch
graue oder blaue wasserstoff wer aber
eben auch energie aufwendig produziert
wird doch das soll sich ändern um die
klimaziele zu erreichen bei der
salzgitter ag setzt man zukünftig
verstärkt auf grünen also
umweltfreundlich produzierten
wasserstoff als energielieferant den
final
tatsächlich 95 prozent co2 vermeidung
erreichen aber ökonomisch muss man das
erstmal stimmen können und der stahl
wird ja am ende kein anderer
und wir können unseren kunden die auch
in einem weltweiten wettbewerb stehen
nicht abverlangen dass die für den
grünen stahl
doppelt oder dreimal so viel bezahlen
sauber aber auch bezahlbar muss die
energie sein um wettbewerbsfähig zu
bleiben das ist bisher das problem beim
grünen wasserstoff der mit hilfe von
wind sonne oder wasserkraft hergestellt
wird die produktion beispielsweise von
grünem wasserstoff ist sehr teuer und
wenn sie den grünen wasserstoff in
konkurrenz zu fossil hergestellten
grauen wasserstoff nehmen dann ist
einfach die produktionskosten um gleich
weit auseinander
und man muss jetzt an verschiedenen
stellen ansetzen um da abhilfe zu
leisten
das ist heute geschehen 9 milliarden
euro investiert die bundesregierung im
rahmen ihrer nationalen wasserstoff
strategie wir wollen bei den neuen
wasserstoff technologie hin zu grünem
wasserstoff weltweit führend seien
als ausrüster für die welt aber auch als
produzenten
wir wollen die nummer eins werden auch
aus gründen unserer wettbewerbsfähigkeit
aber vor allen dingen weil wir wollen
dass unsere ehrgeizigen klimaschutzziele
erreicht werden
der zughersteller alstom ist mit seinen
wasserstoffbetriebenen zügen schon
weltweit führend sie sollen diese
lokomotiven ersetzen zwei
verkehrsbetriebe haben schon bestellt
aber es gibt ein problem die tank
infrastruktur ist es jetzt ganz wichtig
dass eine großflächige tank
infrastruktur in deutschland gibt damit
diese fahrzeuge auch überall in
deutschland fahren können
ein weiteres problem deutschland wird
niemals die mengen an grünem wasserstoff
produzieren können wie gebraucht wird es
ist seine platz und wetter frage
vor diesem hintergrund ist halt das
thema internationale perspektive extrem
wichtig aber technologie kommt aus
deutschland und soll dazu könnt ihr aus
deutschland kommen und das ist ein
relikt in zukunft so unterzeichneten
heute deutschland und marokko einen
partnerschaftsvertrag für eine
produktionsanlage für grünen wasserstoff
der dann per schiff oder irgendwann
vielleicht über eine pipeline zu uns
kommt es wäre eine echte win win
situation
und jetzt stellen sie sich besser an es
geht um wirtschaftskriminalität die das
vorstellungsvermögen normaler menschen
übersteigt die comex affäre eine art
hütchenspiel mit milliarden
beträgen machenschaften die dem staat
das geld aus der tasche ziehen
im detail ist das ziemlich komplex kaum
nachzuvollziehen aber im prinzip ist es
ganz einfach ein investor der aus seinen
aktien dividenden verdient muss darauf
steuer zahlen die bekommt er unter
umständen später erstattet und der trick
liegt jetzt darin zum entscheidenden
zeitpunkt die aktien so verwirrend
schnell hin und her zu verkaufen dass
das finanzamt die erstattung mehrfach
zahlt an mehrere adressen und zwar
milliarden und milliarden von euro
lukrativer und unverschämter als
steuerhinterziehung das ist ein direkter
griff in die staatskasse nun
möglicherweise ist der nicht einmal
strafbar weil technisch korrekt
abgewickelt
es ist eine höllen arbeit die details
aufzuklären
und jetzt könnte es passieren dass der
staat die strafverfolgung verpasst
es droht verjährung dort bewerber
berichtet in diesen akten geht es um
sehr viel geld um steuergeld das fehlt
diese akten gehören zur eigens
eingerichteten comics strafkammer im
bonner landgericht
[Musik]
es gibt eine vielzahl von unterlagen
terabyte von beschlagnahmtem
e-mail-postfächern usw
die analysiert die ausgewertet werden
müssen und das macht es so besonders
schwer weil es hier um geschäfte in
hochkomplexer form an den aktienbörsen
geht mit dem man sich als normaler
jurist nicht einfach durch wird
beschäftigt verfahren die zeit kosten
vor gericht stehen finanzprofis
angeklagte im anzug die sich auskennt
mit einem juristischen tricks zwei
männer hat das bonner landgericht im
märz verurteilt seither ist flaute
dabei ermittelt die kölner
staatsanwaltschaft gegen 880
beschuldigte aber so recht kommt man
nicht voran
es gibt gerade einmal zehn stellen für
diese riesenaufgabe nordrhein westfalens
justizminister versucht zu erklären
wenig personal mag von außen aussehen
aber im augenblick sagt der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt in köln kommen wir mit
dem personal nachrichten dass die kammer
in bonn nicht beschäftigt ist ist auch
allenfalls einen augenblick oder eine
momentaufnahme
am bonner landgericht befürchten sie
jedenfalls wenn die comics verfahren
nicht beschleunigt werden könnten täter
straffrei ausgehen
die deutsche justiz wäre blamiert eine
gefahr die man auch in berlin
registriert hat wir sehen jetzt in
diesen tagen das durchaus die gefahr
besteht eben weil die aufklärung so
lange gedauert dass einige
unterlieferung fallen und da halten wir
das mit der verlängerung der
verfolgungsverjährung auch für ein
richtiges gutes dem justizminister in
düsseldorf hilft das kaum denn die
verlängerte verjährungsfrist wird nur
wenn rechtzeitig ermittelt wird und es
gebe eben zuwenig ermittler lautet
weiter der vorwurf im landtag
entscheidend ist die zehnjahresfrist
innerhalb von zehn jahren muss die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittlungen
aufgenommen haben damit eine verjährung
unterbrechung quasi passiert und wir
verlängern können der justizminister
muster für sorge tragen dass der
rechtsstaat sich nicht zur lachnummer
machen
wenn es kein ermittlungsverfahren gibt
verjährt an comics betrug der im jahr
2010 begangen wurde
schon in diesem jahr die zeit drängt der
stadt droht sich ein zweites mal
vorführen zu lassen erst bei
milliardenbetrug jetzt bei der
strafverfolgung
eine recht komplizierte angelegenheit
ist es auch weiterhin für frauen in eine
führungsposition zu kommen
eine neue studie vergleicht nun die
chancen von managerinnen in
familienunternehmen und dax-konzernen
frank bethmann da lohnt ein genauer
blick ja zumal in beiden fällen die
chance sind nicht gerade gestiegen sind
der typische vorstand eines dax konzerns
ist immer noch männlich auf den 190
vorstand stühlen sitzen dort nur 27
frauen vorstandsvorsitzende ist derzeit
keine einzige in familienunternehmen
sieht es keinen deut besser aus im
gegenteil dort ist das verhältnis der
geschlechter noch ungünstiger das geht
aus einer heute vorgestellten studie
hervor unter den 100 umsatzstärksten
eigentümerfamilien nicht einmal sieben
prozent der führungspositionen sind mit
frauen besetzt bei dax unternehmen sind
es 15 prozent
damit so die stiftung werden chancen
verpasst gemischte führungsteams die
besseren entscheidungen treffen ganz
einfach bei unterschiedliche
perspektiven vorhanden sind
unterschiedlicher hintergründe die sich
gegenseitig ergänzen die in frage
stellen die neues reinbringen es gibt
mehr diskussion und am ende werden die
besseren entscheidungen getroffen dass
das umdenken dennoch oft so schwer fällt
überrascht bei familienunternehmen
besonders firmen wie miele deichmann
oder haribo sind auch deswegen
erfolgreich weil sie die zeichen der
zeit häufig früh genug erkannt haben
beim anteil von frauen in führungsetagen
müssen sie ihr gespür aber erst noch
beweisen
vielen dank peter tschentscher ist
erneut zum ersten bürgermeister von
hamburg gewählt worden
der 54 jahre alte spd-politiker wurde
mit allen 87 stimmen von rot grün für
weitere fünf jahre im amt bestätigt
zuvor hatten spd und grüne den
koalitionsvertrag unterzeichnet seit
2005 10 regiert rot grün in hamburg
ende februar verteidigten sie bei der
bürgerschaftswahl ihre mehrheit gleich
zum fußball zunächst die gewinnzahlen
vom lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 2 11 17
20 36 42 superzahl 1 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 im dfb pokal standen
sich am abend im zweiten halbfinale
bayern münchen und eintracht frankfurt
gegenüber
der favorit aus münchen hat sich am ende
knapp mit 2 1 durchgesetzt und trifft
damit im endspiel am vierten juli auf
bayer leverkusen
claudia neumann die botschaft eindeutig
die motivation riesig das signal
überzeugend der kampf gegen rassismus
nimmt auch im fussball fahrt auf auch
die sportlichen zeichen von beginn an
unmissverständlich der rekordmeister
souverän und dominant vierzehnter minute
petric waldmüllers kranke eins zu null
aber bayern versemmelt anschließend
reihenweise großchancen nach der pause
lässt der rekordmeister frankfurt
leichtfertig aus dem schwitzkasten die
folge 1 1 ausgleich durch den
eingewechselten da costa
bayerns überlegenheit dahin dass es am
ende doch noch für den sieg reicht ist
robert lewandowski und video assistentin
bibiana steinhaus zu verdanken die einen
abseitspfiff in der tour entstehung
zurecht korrigiert 74 minute treffer
zählt bayern gewinnt 2 1 und erreicht
zum 24 mal das dfb pokalfinale
nun schließen wir das journal vor dem
un- leichnams tag mit großen bildern und
eine geschichte nach dem bibelwort von
schwertern die pflugscharen werden es
geht um festungen von hitlers atlantik
wall entlang frankreichs küsten unter
ihnen u-boot basen um seinen
europäischen krieg auf die weltmeere zu
tragen
beton monster die allen bomben
standhielten bis heute zum teil
unzerstörbar
heimat helfen in denen die u-boote
repariert und gerüstet wurden für das
tödliche werk ersatz war der ort auch an
dem sie als helden empfangen und von der
propaganda gefeiert wurden wenn sie heim
kamen mehr als 30.000 der rund 40.000 u
boot fahrer kehrten nicht zurück
das sind schreckliche bauten die stadt
bordeaux hat den iren in ein kunstwerk
verwandelt das seinerseits die kunst
feiert zur eröffnung mit werken von
gustav klimt christel haas war sehr
beeindruckt
[Musik]
die illusion ist perfekt gänsehaut pur
es ist als sei man direkt dabei im jahr
1943 heimkehr eines deutschen u-boots
nach einem kriegseinsatz in die basis
und innerhalb von einer sekunde eine
ganz andere welt eine voller farben gold
blau glitzernd was für ein gegensatz
das einzige reale hier sind die dicken
mauern und das wasser wir sind in einem
ehemaligen deutschen bunker des
atlantiks in bordeaux ein monströser bau
aus stahlbeton allein die decke ist neun
meter dick er hat den krieg überstanden
und konnte auch nicht gesprengt werden
und das wäre sehr gefährlich gewesen
denn die fundamente reichen zwölf meter
in die tiefe
alles drumherum wäre auch mit
eingestürzt jetzt bekommt der kriegs bau
ein neues friedliches leben
digitale kunst installationen die das
brackigen wasser und die hohen mauern in
eine politische traumwelt verwandeln
[Musik]
die werke von gustav klimt und paul klee
in einer ganz anderen dimension
[Musik]
selbst der wasserspiegel ist nie gleich
dieser ort lebt durch seine schiere
größe durch die spiegelungen im wasser
erlebt
[Musik]
eine 12.000 quadratmeter illusion die
bei jedem schritt neue perspektiven
bietet erzeugt von 90 videoprojektoren
verbunden mit 100 kilometern gab aber
geht das denn überhaupt ein bunker der
so viel ästhetik ausstrahlt ich glaube
nicht dass das eine verharmlosung des
krieges oder der geschichte ist diese
u-boot basis gehört zum kulturerbe von
bordeaux und zum kultur erbe europas
es ist auf jeden fall ein intensives
erlebnis wenn die besucher denken sie
seien aus der zeit gefallen sagt der
museumsdirektor
dann haben wir alles richtig gemacht so
kann ein langer arbeitstag zu ende gehen
wir wünschen ihnen einen schönen rest
abend und sehen uns morgen wieder zur
journal zeit 21.45 schönen feiertag
schlüssel
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unbeständiges
wetter herrscht weiterhin im süden
deutschlands dafür sorgt dieses tief
hier über norditalien dann gibt es noch
ein weiteres tief das rauscht von den
britischen inseln richtung iberische
halbinsel bringt noch kühle luft dort
hin und setzt sich auch noch fest
die kühle luft zu erkennt man hier 15
bis 20 grad sind es in westeuropa
richtig heiß 30 bis 35 grad teilweise
bis nach sibirien
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es im
westen trockene abschnitte aber diese
schauer hier die ziehen allmählich nach
nordwesten im süden kompakte wolken und
regen mit dem tief aus dem süden ja und
die temperaturen sinken auf 14 grad in
schleswig holstein und 8 grad am
alpenrand
morgen dann einige schauer und gewitter
über mit den bergen halb hauptsächlich
zum beispiel richtung erzgebirge und am
alpenrand sonst gibt es auch mal
trockene abschnitte aber im norden ist
es ziemlich dicht und hier zieht regen
durch die temperaturen erreichen dabei
24 grad nach osten hin und 17 grad
direkt an der ostsee
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
freitag gibt es einzelne gewitter wieder
bevorzugt in den bergen nach süden
sonnenschein bis 30 grad heißt so ein
bisschen heiser aber dann auch
gewittriger und schüler teils mit
unwetterartigen gewittern werte bis 31
grad am samstag oder auch in der nacht
auf den sonntag wird es gewittrig
bleiben und am sonntag selbst damit ein
schöner abend